i do buy a lot of wwe merch at least in
my peak watching but i bought like all
of your guys
you know it's funny before you guys got
called up so before we got called though
that's love so for those people who
don't know as a pro wrestler i wrestled
in the wwe with the tag partner big cat
saying you guys you know yeah so me and
another guy named cass he was uh he's
now w morrissey keep your eyes peeled
for him just a seven foot tall giant bbs
tnt i mean maybe we'll see some more of
him in the future but he just did a spot
on aw big caz uh my former tag team
partner seven foot tall played
basketball at nyu natural connection me
being from hackensack new jersey him
being free you played football right
yeah i played college bowl yeah um it's
funny i didn't play an athlete on tv by
any means bro as a pro wrestler you know
you could hit the ropes jump over the
top do the flips and that wasn't my
gimmick that wasn't my my deal i just
talked that [ __ ] man yeah it's crazy
because uh i remember watching you guys
in nxt and i just remember be like you
guys got the craziest crowd pops and
then your mic work was like yeah you
know i i owe it all to that crowd bro as
you would say you know what like so what
you're talking about is nxt is the forum
system of the wwe at the time at the
time they didn't have any shows that
left like the state of florida so you
were living in tampa and me we were
becoming you know a wrestling tag team
me and big cass yeah on the indie kind
of scene of wwe like just florida but
then we left florida and then they did
the barclays center yeah i was at the i
was at barclays that was a summer
summerslam at 2015. we went from like
literally we'd be wrestling in a little
armory on a thursday night i have the
summerslam t-shirt or the uh the the nxt
takeover t-shirt yeah and i didn't keep
any of that [ __ ] man i should i should
have kept a book you guys wrestled that
night that was the night of uh
it was sasha
charlotte and bailey yeah they're the
first people to come to the curtain that
weekend and holy [ __ ] with a homecoming
man for sure i had the yankee pinstripes
on i remember that my mind's my shout
out my boy spiff tv had me dripping yo
you always had the crazy fits oh he had
you know like this is a gift from spiff
man shout out my man spiff like these
mm-hmm spiff's a big wrestling fan as
well this is real so you know uh
wrestling man it i owe a lot to it it
was a great opportunity but for me it
was a runway too you know i was known
for the sneakers and and the swag and
the clothes and like that barclays i had
that michelin s yankees with the new
york city skyline by my seamstress put
in a leopard with biggie the picture of
him in the coochie count and the money
would would have i put a [ __ ] statue
of liberty crown on him and i wrote it
was all the dream like i was swagged the
[ __ ] out nobody else was wearing the
jays at the time
yeah but i saw it as a runway like pro
wrestling like yo this is like a great
opportunity to like be seen so what you
want to walk out there in underwear i
mean all credit to my [ __ ] dwayne
johnson and steve austin
hulk hogan they did it dawg but i was
fighting an uphill battle yeah you're a
smaller guy and i feel like um
i feel like you kind of like made
everybody kind of elevate their mic work
because i mean
like when you guys i felt like you you
were the most entertaining like it was
like it was like you and paul hey never
been nothing like me and there never
will be no it hasn't happened yet some
of your promos you would cover just for
ain't no comparisons you could draw
because i had this great blessing of
dusty rhodes in my corner that allowed
me to write my own [ __ ] whereas most
people didn't have that opportunity now
who the [ __ ] right now in the situation
is going to tell vince mcmahon let him
say what he wants you know i had dusty
rhodes in nxt go to vince like this kid
his mother got it let him do his [ __ ]
and now all of a sudden i'm writing my
own [ __ ] and saying my own [ __ ] and cena
cosigns me early
so now cena's in your corner and he
wants you to say your own [ __ ] see when
you're in a room with other wrestlers
and a producer and a writer and you guys
are green and you're new in the business
like you don't have a say in like you
know and for one imagine this all right
we go out on tv there's seven seven
minutes blocked out for our segment
right you got seven minutes curtain to
curtain from the time you go through the
curtain to the time you get your beauty
shot at the top of the ramp of the
victor right right now
within that seven minutes you're going
to a commercial break that'll be two
minutes so you have five so now you have
you have five but it's right smack dab
in the middle but you gotta still
entertain the crowd when the cameras
aren't rolling for so now it's a live
audience you're working for too
but you're really catering to the
millions on tv right but if you're enzo
and you come out talking [ __ ] and you
got opponents in the ring we've only got
five minutes and i'm going to match with
four people not two i got big cast my
tag partner and i got another two guys
so you mean to tell me i'm gonna talk
[ __ ] about you for three minutes
and then i'm gonna do wrestling moves to
you for two minutes what the [ __ ] are
you gonna do
what are you gonna do
so my job was real easy real simple i'm
gonna talk and that's it i'm not allowed
to do wrestling moves because we have
[ __ ] time for it bro you know i got
to make the heels look like they're
beating my ass if i don't beat somebody
who the [ __ ] did i just beat you didn't
beat nobody what the [ __ ] if you're just
talking [ __ ] about them and then they
ain't credible and then you get the the
the the high climatic tag big cast code
that was the recipe man so it's like
probably the easiest job i go out i'm
back [ __ ] by the boom how are you
doing somebody hits me from behind right
yeah now i'm in the corner and i'm
getting beat up and then you're like
cass hasn't even gotten here you know
whatever simplest recipe ever yeah open
every nxt show around the world open
every wwe show around the world this
works big guys in the corner we can't
get them in enzo says you're soft they
spell it out soft enzo gets hit i'm just
getting beat up bro so i never had to
show that i was an athlete i never had
to wrestle all i had to really do was
tag in the big guy and i had to learn
how to take an entertaining ass kicking
and draw empathy for people and make
them wanna so that was really my forte i
think was selling in wrestling and what
we call selling
hey that is a serious uh talent